[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a este especial
deportivo en france 24 como es habitual
terminamos el año con un repaso a los y
las deportistas más destacadas de estos
12 meses marcados obviamente por los
juegos olímpicos de tokio no es un
ranking no es una lista que presentemos
en orden de mejores a peores es una
selección elaborada en nuestra redacción
de deportes y vamos a empezar con fútbol
con el jugador que hemos elegido como el
mejor futbolista del año es lionel messi
el argentino que este año conquistó la
copa américa y levantó su primer título
de mayores con la albiceleste además
ganó su séptimo balón de oro a sus 34
años para analizar el rendimiento de la
pulga tengo el placer de contar con sara
castro la directora del diario 'as'
colombia quien nos acompaña desde la
ciudad de bogotá
sara como siempre bienvenida y es un
placer tenerte con nosotros
un gusto para mí estar hablando de todos
estos talentos que de onda que hablar
durante este año para cómo describirías
la versión de lionel messi que vimos
este año cuando en esa copa américa se
dijo tanto que era el mes y más
colectivo
a ver yo creo que el principal cambio de
leonel messi tiene que ver desde el
liderazgo y es un liderazgo que pasa de
ser simplemente futbolístico de su
capacidad de hacer cosas en la cancha y
de generar resultados alrededor de esto
un liderazgo que pasa por su influencia
en un vestuario por la responsabilidad
que tiene en todos los otros ámbitos del
juego y esto es muy importante y se ha
visto no solo en el barcelona en su
momento ahora en un parís también mal en
el que tiene que llegar a acomodarse
pero sobre todo en la selección
argentina en donde se vio un cambio
generacional desde el punto de vista del
juego evidentemente con el paso de los
años y se reacomodan la posición
priorizando no los desgastes físicos
sino más su capacidad de influir en eso
en el juego colectivo en la toma de
decisiones y por supuesto
y aunque usted le puede cuestionar la
velocidad su gambeta y freno que es uno
de esos puntos característicos de como
siempre se lleva a los rivales
no no ha cambiado sigue teniendo este
este vínculo con la pelota que lo hace
un jugador de un nivel excepcional
algunos dirán bueno y por qué eligieron
a lionel messi y no eligieron a robert
lewandowski quien fue el ganador de la
bota de oro porque no se elija jorginho
que fue doble campeón ganó la eurocopa
con italia y la champions league con el
chelsea quizá jorginho en otros años
habría sido el elegido como el balón de
oro en que fue mejor messi que ellos dos
lo de jorginho es excepcional o un
volante fundamental no solo para el
chelsea sino también para esta nueva
idea para esta nueva italia que vimos en
la eurocopa de bandos y también un
goleador es impresionante con unas
características además un recorrido y
una carrera que no sólo avala la
temporada sino también un jugador maduro
que ha sabido estar pieza fundamental
del bayern múnich ahora yo creo que este
triunfo en el balón de oro de messi
también es un triunfo contra el
eurocentrismo no es valorar esta
consecución de la copa américa en la
cual leonel messi fue fundamental y como
decíamos en una selección argentina que
ya ha tenido que gestionar muchos
fracasos en los últimos años y en este
caso messi que empieza a dejar este rol
de ser el jugador eje para hacer uno más
pero siempre evidentemente con esa clase
y sobre todo poniendo a jugar y mejor a
sus compañeros entonces creo que me
decía además ha sido un poco penalizado
no porque él ha hecho
del hecho rutinario lo que es
extraordinario y si uno compara los
números evidentemente le van dos que
tienen más goles pero también su
participada participación de messi en el
juego en los equipos por los que pasan
no se mira de la misma manera entonces
creo que los periodistas que votaron por
el balón de oro tuvieron esa
sensibilidad de ver la influencia de
leonel messi no sólo como ese jugador
que pueda anotar muchos goles que maneja
una cantidad de récords impresionante y
lo que también en este periodo de su
carrera es un jugador maduro y que
además competirá en sudamérica es
bastante complicado y más ganarle una
final a un brasil como el de tite que
está haciendo pues uno de los de los
equipos que además llega como candidatos
al mundial de kaká seguimos hablando del
fútbol sara vamos a hablar ahora de la
rama femenina para nosotros la ganadora
del balón de oro es también nuestra
elegida como la mejor futbolista del año
hablamos de alexia putellas la española
que milita en el fc barcelona tiene 27
años y se convierte en la segunda
persona de su país que gana el balón de
oro alex se ganó la temporada pasada el
triplete con el barça copa liga y
champions para qué papel jugó alexia en
este rendimiento perfecto las culés
hay que recordar que alex ya venía a ser
elegida como la mejor jugadora por la
uefa después de anotar 29 goles y dar 24
asistencias en la pasada temporada a ver
hay que destacar que no es una delantera
siempre los números de los jugadores que
son delante los llaman la atención es
una jugadora muy inteligente una web una
volante no sólo es importante para el
barcelona sino también para la selección
de españa española y es muy interesante
cuando ella descubre describe su juego y
es como le gusta estar en una posición
en la que no sólo juega bien sino que
hace jugar mejor a sus compañeras le
encanta jugar por el centro del campo en
donde toma decisiones para dejar en
posición de ventaja a sus compañeras
bien sea numérico posicional
y esto es fundamental triplete histórico
para el barcelona liga con liga copa y
champions league una champions league
muy disputada con unos equipos que
venían digamos tradicionalmente
quedándose con este título así que creo
que es un triunfo para una jugadora que
colectivamente e hizo mejor a sus
compañeras pero que también tiene un
talento excepcional y que evidentemente
sola crack que destaca por encima de la
toma el balón de oro está premiando a
alexia putellas o está premiando la
temporada del barcelona
previa a alexia putellas pero también
premia al fútbol español un fútbol
español que además lleva por dentro unas
luchas por conseguir hacer una liga
profesional y también una jugadora que
está vuelto referente no sólo de niñas y
lo de niños en el país por esa capacidad
y condición que tiene no es una jugadora
absolutamente disciplinada una jugadora
que es modelo referente y que además
como de citi ambos ahora tiene esa
capacidad de influir en el juego lo del
barcelona está absolutamente el
llamativo porque además premió un
proceso y estamos hablando de que el
fútbol es un deporte colectivo que viven
entre estos talentos excepcionales
pueden destacar y pueden digamos llamar
la atención por por sus números pero
sólo en el momento en el que logran
influir y lograr resultados colectivos
es que se puede premiar esto entonces yo
creo que el triunfo de alexia putellas
al final habla de un trabajo también del
fútbol español de muchos años de un
proyecto en el que él apostó barcelona
de además estaba nominada con muchas
otras de los jugadores lo que habla de
un colectivo con unas individualidades
excepcionales pero también esa capacidad
de liderazgo y de generar transformación
que también atraviesa lo que pasa en el
campo de juego cinco jugadoras del
barcelona estado en amenazas y 'balón de
oro' sara muchísimas gracias como
siempre la directora del diario de
colombia que nos acompaña aquí en france
24 dejamos el fútbol para hablar de una
de las grandes revelaciones que tuvimos
en los juegos olímpicos de tokio tiene
22 años es brasileña y era un nombre que
no sonaba para nada como una de las
grandes aspirantes en su deporte de la
gimnasta de rebeca andrade campeona
olímpica en el salto del potro sub
campeona olímpica en el ejercicio
completo campeona mundial en el salto
del potro también y subcampeona mundial
en las barras asimétricas sobre ella nos
habla desde río de janeiro nuestra
corresponsal valeria saccone
la gimnasta brasileña andrade ha sido
una de las grandes revelaciones en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio pero la
medallista tiene a su espalda una
historia de superación porque es hija de
una madre soltera que tuvo que trabajar
muy duro limpiando casas para sacar
adelante una familia de siete hijos no
es una excepción en un país donde hay 11
millones y medio de madres solteras que
encabezan hogares monoparentales
además rebeca es un atleta negra en un
país brasil donde el racismo estructural
todavía es muy fuerte y eso a pesar de
que la mayoría de la población el 54 por
ciento se declaren negra en el censo
ella mostró mucho valor e iniciativa al
escoger la música baile de favela para
su competición individual reivindicando
así las raíces culturales de la
periferia de sao paulo donde creció la
superación también ha sido física porque
ha tenido que recuperarse de tres
roturas de ligamentos en la rodilla que
la mantuvieron alejada de las
competiciones durante bastante tiempo
consiguió volver en marzo de 2020 y de
hecho el retraso de los juegos olímpicos
debido a la pandemia de el coronavirus
la benefició porque tuvo más tiempo para
recuperarse en tokio hace lucio en el
salto del potro que le rindió el oro ha
sido la primera atleta brasileña en
conseguir una medalla en esta disciplina
seguimos hablando de protagonistas de
tokio 2020 obviamente en pleno año
olímpico tenemos que incluir dos figuras
del atletismo para yo cuento aquí con
nuestra especialista de la materia el
mar es un mar gracias por estar con
nosotros un placer y vamos a empezar
hablando con una de las figuras carsten
a walt con el noruego que este año ganó
el oro olímpico en los 400 metros vallas
y con récord del mundo
gomar porque casi igual con fue elegido
como el atleta del año fueron no
solamente uno sino dos récords mundiales
los que él impuso recordemos que poco
antes de los juegos olímpicos había
bajado uno de los récords más longevos
del atletismo el de kevin jones young
tenía desde 1992 mi gente es 46 78 él lo
llevó a 46 72 poco antes de los juegos y
en los juegos hace pues la gran hazaña
de convertirse en el primer y único
hombre de la historia que baja de los 46
segundos en los 400 metros con vallas
buena marca que incluso recuerdo mucho
la narración de su juego suele en vigo
es que en los 400 metros lisos hubiera
sido una muy buena marca claro es una
marca que da para meterse en finales y
estar disputando medallas probablemente
en algunos contextos totalmente que tal
vez no sea el olímpico pero si un
contexto continental perfectamente
podría estarse buscando medallas con esa
marca tenía dos grandes rivales en ryan
creados el récord del mundo de
lanzamiento de peso y campeón olímpico
también y armand hindú plantease el
sueco que se impuso en el salto con
práctica en los juegos olímpicos porque
fue mejor el que ellos dos es cierto que
cárter armando plantease logra mantener
el mismo dominio en 2021 que había
logrado en el año precedente cuando
impuso sus récord mundiales es cierto
que raya krauser hizo en el mismo año un
récord mundial un récord olímpico y
récord mundial bajo techo por unos
márgenes enormes pero hay que pensar en
esa final que disputó kart en wharton y
pensar que los dos atletas a los que
derrotó a los que confinó a la plata y
el bronce en los 400 con vallas
corrieron ambos por debajo del récord
mundial de kevin con el que el récord
precedente que había y hay que pensar
también qué rey benjamin el
estadounidense venía de correr una marca
a cinco centésimas del récord de que
pocas semanas antes de los juegos
olímpicos y ante rivales de ese calibre
logra imponerse carsten warhol además
que no es poca cosa bajar casi un
segundo en una prueba velocidad una
prueba muy rápida con la polémica de
esas zapatillas deportivas de las que
hablamos en su día y como la mejor
atleta del año tenemos a una velocista
es el intenso en la triada jamaiquina de
29 años campeona en los 100 y 200 metros
lisos en tokio al igual que hizo en río
2016 primera mujer que revalida el
título olímpico en esas distancias
además en tokio también fue campeona en
el relevo 4 por 100
omar podemos decir que la intensión es
la reina indiscutible de la velocidad
sin duda ha habido
otras tres mujeres que han logrado
revalidar
concretamente los 100 metros estamos
hablando de que dos mujeres que el
diverso
en los años en los juegos olímpicos de
amberes guayo matáis pero la primera que
lo logra en estos tiempos modernos es el
infame son también es la quinta mujer
que gana tres medallas en el atletismo
de juegos olímpicos pero es apenas la
segunda que lo hace en pruebas de
velocidad después de florence
griffith-joyner aparte que ese récord de
esa marca de 1054 que hizo en oregón una
de las válidas de la diamond league en
la coloca probablemente como la
plusmarquista mundial sentimental para
mucha gente que no necesariamente cree
en esa leyenda de florence griffith la
actual dueña del récord del mundo y lo
hablamos mucho y que no llegó el
entonces and como gran favorita sus
juegos olímpicos de tokio llegó un poco
en la sombra shelly ann fraser pryce
venía me corregirá con la segunda
tercera mejor marca de la historia y era
la gran favorita en ese momento y
thompson dijo que no era la segunda
mujer más rápida de la historia la
tercera mejor marca porque había un 10
61 que había marcado florence
griffith-joyner antes ella tenía 10 60
creo que habla mucho esta rivalidad de
la manera en que el atletismo jamaiquino
ha ido desarrollándose porque estas
mujeres estuvieron a lo largo de todo el
año pues disputándose el protagonismo
precisamente de eso de la siguiente
pregunta ya no estaba usain bolt pero
jamaica sigue dominando la velocidad de
una manera o de otra
cuál es el secreto para empezar está
jamaica enclavada en un área del área
del caribe
que siempre ha sido protagonista de
velocidad basada en una tradición de
eventos como por ejemplo los oscar y
festa games que es un evento en el que
se enfrentan trinitarios atletas de
grenada que tuvimos aunque james también
en el en el podio de juegos olímpicos
entonces es un contexto sumamente
competitivo en el caso del femenino este
año tuvimos a tres mujeres y eso habla
también de la profundidad que se tiene a
tres mujeres ocupando el podio porque ya
enrique jackson que era una corredora de
400 que se convirtió en corredora de 100
metros estuvo también presente en él eso
nos habla de la profundidad de que tiene
la velocidad del atletismo de máquina
nuestra audiencia venezolana tus
compatriotas y eran buenos y el lema
rojas fue campeona olímpica con un
récord del mundo muy longevo que estaba
vigente porque yo crema rojas no le pudo
ganar a él entonces como atleta del año
a ver hay que pensar por supuesto que la
hazaña de yolimar es extraordinaria pero
hay que pensar también en que lograr
repetir un triplete de la velocidad 100
200 y 4% como lo hizo y la información
general tanto en río como ahora en tokio
no es cosa que se da todos los días
aparte esa marca de 1054 que él hay que
hizo en oregón la coloca en un sitial
histórico
importante además de que
psicológicamente el área de la velocidad
siempre ha ocupado una primacía a la
hora de tomar este tipo de decisiones y
siempre ha sido un conflicto permanente
del atletismo internacional lograr parar
pruebas de campo digamos en la misma
consideración especial que se tiene con
las de pista vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces el otro año en el mundial de
orengo porque ya yulimar ha anticipado
que quiere hacer triple salto y salto
largo y que quiere a los 16 metros en
salto triple es decir quiere aumentar el
récord y creo que también quiere romper
el récord mundial en salto largo ella
dijo de hecho en una entrevista que se
le hizo que en un evento en el que
estuvo haciendo una extraordinaria marca
un 7 27 sino un recuerdo mal en salto
largo en esa oportunidad estuvo saltando
por encima del récord del mundo
increíble de tomar muchísimas gracias
como siempre un placer 30 aquí para
hablar de atletismo vamos a seguir
hablando de estos juegos olímpicos
porque también hubo una mujer que fue
una gran protagonista para cerrar este
bloque terminamos en las piscinas porque
allí es la australiana emma mansión y su
historia ganó siete medallas solamente
en esa edición de los juegos cuatro
medallas de ellas de oro un registro
difícil de igualar y superando el
rendimiento de estrellas como la
estadounidense katie l the king para
conocer más acerca de la historia de
esta mujer vamos a melbourne con el
informe de nuestro corresponsal
camilo montoya
la nadadora australiana emma mansión con
27 años ha ganado 11 medallas olímpicas
en dos participaciones en río de janeiro
y en los más recientes de tokio en tokio
al ganar 7 se convirtió en la primera
nadadora en lograr este número de
medallas en una sola edición de los
juegos y en la segunda que consigue ese
número de preseas junto con la gimnasta
soviética maría coro joska ya quien lo
hizo en 1952 sin duda 2021 será un año
inolvidable para la deportista más
premiada en toda la historia de
australia
emma empezó a nadar desde muy pequeña y
lo lleva en su adn su padre y su hermano
compitieron en los olímpicos y su madre
a nivel nacional la natación es muy
importante en australia es el segundo
país con más medallas olímpicas en este
deporte con 188 después de estados
unidos que tiene 553 su disciplina y sus
logros históricos han hecho que emma sea
muy popular en australia en varias
entrevistas ha dicho que lo más
conmovedor de sus siete medallas de
tokio fue que ocurrieron mientras la
mitad de la población australiana estaba
en confinamiento por kobe 19 y los
australianos le agradecieron masivamente
a través de redes sociales por esa
felicidad por sus logros
emma matías dice que tiene todavía mucho
para dar y por eso ahora entrena para
los olímpicos de verano de parís 2024
es momento de hablar de ciclismo sin
duda de nuevo el esloveno está de poch
ayer se exhibió como el mejor pedalista
del año campeón del tour de francia a la
lieja bastoña lieja el giro de lombardía
la tirreno adriático y bronce olímpico
entre otros logros por eso me acompaña
nuestro compañero leonel púlsar
especialista en esta materia que tal yo
muy bien juan gracias vamos a hablar de
un poco hacer que este año ganó ya con
el cartel de favorito no fue una
revelación como en el 2020 eso le da más
valor a esta temporada sí yo creo como
tú decías el en 2020 cuando vean a
tareas por cancha del tour de france es
una sorpresa creo que hasta para él es
una sorpresa porque nadie lo esperaba y
él tampoco pero de confirmar es siempre
es lo más difícil en deportes no
solamente en ciclismo de ganar en el
primer título es muy difícil pero de
confirmar ganarlo otra vez cuando tienes
el cartel de favorito es más complicado
y de adeit porque ya hizo una temporada
que es excepcional el tour de france que
hizo es excepcional más más grande
digamos que el año anterior porque ganó
igual ganó ganó tres etapas como en 2020
pero este año lo ganó con una forma
mucho más espectacular digamos porque
llegaba como esta etiqueta de favorito y
en la primera crono ya empezó a marcar
la diferencia sobre sus rivales en la
primera etapa de montaña la no la gana
pero hace una diferencia enorme sobre
sus rivales y se quedó casi sin rivales
hasta el final y fue un dominio total de
poca sal sobre este tour de francia
también lo que hace su temporada
excepcional en comparación con 2020 es
lo que mencionabas al inicio que no
solamente ganó el tour de francia sino
que ganó también dos clásicas que son
monumentos del ciclismo lieja bastoña
lieja y el giro de lombardía que son
otro monumento del ciclismo eso nadie lo
había hecho este siglo en el ciclismo
moderno nadie lo logró él lo hizo y
antes de él había solamente dos
ciclistas que son leyendas de este
deporte que son fausto coppi y eddy
mercks entonces es por eso es
excepcional el el año de detalles pocas
charcas sobre todo después de ver ese
gran dominó el tour de francia lo que
pensamos todos en una carrera de tres
semanas va a ser imposible ganarle a
este chico y si sigue en ese estado
forma tiene rival sí yo creo que tiene
rivales hacer previsiones en deportes ya
sabes que es un deporte muy arriesgado y
vamos a ver lo que pasa en 2022 en el
papel podemos decir que no es que para
ganar va a ganar tres cuatro cinco y
seis tour de francia yo creo que es más
difícil que esto porque vamos a ver de
nuevo que su principal rival es su
compatriota el esloveno también primo
sólo gris que si tiene un poquito más de
suerte o menos de mala suerte quizás que
puede rivalizar con él porque creo que
es el que es más completo en la en el
pelotón actual creo que es rock bridge
es quizás el único que puede rivalizar
con poca chad si no tiene caídas y no
tiene elección hay que ver esto hay que
ver también si citada época chat no no
va a caer por ejemplo en el próximo
doctor de francia que es muy complicado
que sale de dinamarca
va a pasar entre parís youtube que es
una etapa muy complicada con muchas
trampas digamos con muchas posibilidades
de caídas por ejemplo hay que ver como
poca char puede puede jugar con esto y
si todos sus rivales están al tope a
este momento hay que ver si logra
conseguir un tercer título del tour de
francia pensar en una bonita carrera en
un 'gran bernal al cien por cien contra
on rizada con trata de poca sal al cien
por cien lo que ya vimos en este 2021
fue al margen del tour de francia en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio una carrera
muy dura tuvo poca echará buen nivel y
el que ganó fue richard carpas también
por destacar esa buena gesta del
ecuatoriano si de richard carpas y hace
parte de los mejores de ciclistas de los
últimos años no hay que olvidar esto que
ganó el giro y su apoyo en el tour de
francia ganó los juegos olímpicos este
año
es algo que hay que destacar también y
en la forma de desarrollo de realizar
carpas y él dice siempre que tiene
solamente cuatro años de experiencia
como profesional que llegó muy tarde al
ciclismo
richard carpas y está mejorando año tras
año nos decía en una entrevista
que estaba buscando los detalles de
mejorar la crono por ejemplo de está aún
mejor en la montaña son cosas que
también no hay que destacar que dichas
nos puede reservar unas sorpresas como
andando como tú decías este año hay que
ver no sé si son rivales de gáldar para
el tour de francia pero el ciclismo no
agregará muchas sorpresas y muchas veces
buenas en américa latina entonces hay
que esperar para richard y para llegar a
ver nada también ha sido del lío
muchísimas gracias por haber sido con
nosotros un placer como siempre estar
contigo es momento de hablar de tenés
sin duda el mejor tenista del año es el
serbio novak djokovic campeón de tres
gran slams al balcánico solamente le
falta imponerse en el abierto de eeuu
para completar el gran slam con las
cuatro coronas de la temporada djokovic
sumas y veinte grand slam en total los
mismos que el español rafael nadal y el
suizo roger federer djokovic aspiraba
este 2021 incluso completar un año
perfecto no le ganó los primeros tres
gran slam del año y llegó a los juegos
olímpicos de tokio con la posibilidad de
ganar ese oro olímpico y después de
levantar el abierto de eeuu habría sido
el denominado grand slam dorado sin
embargo en tokio terminó por fuera de
las medallas y en una cita en donde el
campeón fue el alemán alexander zverev
luego pese a ser el favorito cayó en la
final del abierto de eeuu contra el ruso
danila medvedev el palmarés de djokovic
quedó así campeón del abierto de
australia roland garros o wimbledon el
master 1000 de parís entre los grandes
títulos y también número uno del año es
la séptima ocasión que djokovic termina
como mejor de la temporada un récord
dentro de la rama masculina
y nos subimos ahora al cuadrilátero
porque también hay alguien que sigue
siendo el rey
el canelo álvarez tuvo sin dudas un gran
daño el boxeador mexicano ganó todo lo
que disputó en esta temporada y se
consolidó como la gran estrella en este
deporte todo el análisis de por qué el
canelo está en esta lista lo tiene
nuestro compañero en la redacción luís
méndez
desde que son cuatro los organismos que
rigen en los destinos del boxeo
internacional solamente un puñado de
pugilistas ha logrado hacerse con los
cuatro títulos en las diferentes
divisiones uno de ellos es
latinoamericano se trata de saúl álvarez
es mexicano y quien es apodado 'el
canelo' éste consiguió en noviembre de
2021 hacerse con el título que le
faltaba para ser campeón indiscutido en
la división de las 168 libras al vencer
por nocaut al estadounidense que le
plantó con ello deja su registro con más
de 50 victorias 39 de ellas por nocaut
es un revés y dos empates su única
derrota data de septiembre del año 2013
cuando cayó frente a floyd mayweather
una derrota que más allá de hacerle caer
en su carrera le permitió
impulso suficiente para cosechar 15
victorias y tan sólo un empate hasta la
actualidad pero esto pareciera no ser
suficiente para él nacido en guadalajara
que aspira a más cosas dentro del
deporte y por él y ha puesto su atención
en la división de los cruceros con ello
busca su quinto título mundial y ya
recibió el permiso del consejo mundial
de boxeo para acceder a una pelea en
esta división una división que por
cierto antecede a la de los pesos
pesados pero esto podría convertirse en
el máximo logro del nacido en méxico en
los próximos años un legado que será
bastante grande y que dejará un listón
muy elevado para quienes quieran
sucederlo dentro de esta disciplina
terminamos este repaso con un piloto que
nos entregó uno de los momentos más
emocionantes quizás en toda la historia
del deporte el neerlandés max verstappen
conquistó su primer mundial de fórmula 1
después de adelantar al británico lewis
hamilton siete veces campeón en la
última vuelta del gran premio de abu
dhabi el que cierro la temporada a sus
24 años verstappen levantó a bordo de su
red bulls el mundial de pilotos más
disputado en los últimos años en esta
temporada ganó 10 grandes premios sobre
8 de hamilton en la clasificación final
se impuso frente a su rival de mercedes
por apenas 8 puntos su madre su cumbre
también fue piloto de carreras y su
padre yo se estuvo en la fórmula1 sobre
el hablo max versa pen tras su victoria
toma edad cuando vi a mi padre al salir
del auto ese fue un momento muy especial
porque empezamos a hablar el uno al otro
de darnos cuenta de que lo que hacíamos
en los días de los karts ya sabes
viajando por toda europa juntos en la
furgoneta y luego te miras a los ojos y
piensas lo hicimos ganamos el campeonato
mundial
y en este repaso de los 10 mejores
deportistas del año no nos podemos
obviar no podemos olvidar del papel de
figuras como simón vice quien resaltó a
un nuevo nivel la importancia de la
salud mental en el alto rendimiento
sobre ese tema profundiza nuestra
compañera de omar esa junto con rodrigo
sedano en otro especial que pueden
disfrutar aquí y en francés 24 y con
esto terminamos como siempre gracias por
estar con nosotros quédense en nuestra
pantalla porque la información continua
[Música]